if you're going to buy into the idea of
of capitalism at all then you have to
you have to believe in growth
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Ken Carson he's
the editor in chief of the New York
Observer a role he's filled since 2013
the New York Observer is one of the most
vibrant and exciting weekly newspapers
in the country Ken thanks for talking to
us thanks for having me here Nick talk a
bit about your vision for the New York
Observer and I asked this for two
reasons one is that as a young man
living in New Jersey and then later in
New York and working the New York
Observer was one of these great hault
weekly papers that define what was great
about New York it had just rich voices
interesting stories people complaining
and kvetching and arguing on the
editorial pages great pictures by Drew
Friedman and the like so in that way I
want to know what your vision of this
paper that was so important to me
growing up is but more importantly in
the alternative media landscape it
reinvigorate along with the New York
press it reinvigorated journalism writ
large in New York in the 80s and since
how do you how do you see the observer
working in today's world which is much
more dynamic than ever
you just gave like a beautiful preamble
forward exactly what I see I you you
called it all weekly but I think it
occupies a different space there's
really nothing like it in the country
every city has its alt weekly but no
other city has this sort of alt weekly
for the upper-crust and that's that's
what the the New York Observer is
but I mean it's not something like you
don't have to make $100,000 a year in
order to read it no I'm sure your
advertisers would prefer that but well a
lot of them do luckily a lot of our
readers do but but like I was saying
when I was brand new in New York City I
I turn to you know Jim wind offs
off-the-record column just to literally
find out who was being hired and fired
in media this was before the Internet
this was you know when to figure out you
know what what
Random House even was you had to read
the New York Observer the observer was
the starting point of Sex in the City
that's right and so I mean this is the
type of thing that it was Charlie and it
seemed to be coming out of a kind of New
Journalism mode where the reported the
reporting was top-notch but it was also
highly personal or highly stylized and a
lot of personality so what is its role
now we live in a in a city and in a
media scape where there are a few titans
I mean things like the New York Times
are doing well but everybody knows
that's not where the
action as the action is almost any place
else well you know I think people are
hungrier than ever for for the sort of
warm intimate relationship that readers
felt that they had with the New York
Observer during the period you're
mentioning so I've kind of doubled down
on that you mentioned sex in the city
Candace Bushnell great writer
chronicling her her life and that those
of her friends and so one of the first
things I did when we started really
going the hunt for another great sex
columnist we found one in Jasmine Loeb
she writes a beautiful column about what
what sex and romance and intimacy and
really lack of intimacy is like in you
know the mid 2000 teens
Richard Kirshenbaum great voice in our
paper chronicling the you know there's
incredible weird insecurities of the
ultra-rich like one of his columns a
couple weeks ago was hilarious it's
about how you can barely have a dinner
party because this one won't eat gluten
and that one doesn't eat meat and this
one's a vegan and that one only eats
local foods and wants to know where the
radishes were grown cetera and it's it's
it's not just hilarious there's a
there's a thread running through all of
this which is how hard it is to find
your place in New York City the New York
Observer is about trying to make that
that journey a little bit more how does
that play in the national scene because
you know that that defines it for New
York and then what do you have
aspirations for being a voice you have
will get into your politics and your
political background you worked and
wrote with Rudy Giuliani you know what
what are the politics of the New York
Observer and how do they exceed kind of
being quarantined within the Hudson
River that's a great question you know
the politics of New York Observer are
not my personal politics I come from a
political world and I think there was
some nervousness or raised eyebrows when
when someone who had been a partisan
political figure like myself became the
editor but you know everybody has their
personal views and I try really hard to
of course they inform what I do but I'm
one member of a tutorial or and the
politics of a the New York Observer is
really where where Mike Bloomberg was
it's this sort of pro-business but but
very an anti soda if you were to see me
walking I have a giant soda on my desk
at all times in violation of that so
we'll talk about Bloomberg and and
Giuliani was like this time and it's
interesting because as he moved into the
national scene he had to and I did to
his detriment he tried to fit more and
more tightly into a Republican box but
as new you in New York what he was what
was interesting about him is that he was
pro-business but he was uh so pro gay
rights for marriage equality or whatever
things that he couldn't be on a national
yeah I want to correct a few things I
never thought
Rudy changed anything or emphasized
anything differently I think that's
totally wrong I think Rudy took a ton of
flack in New York for being perceived as
a right winger you remember him trying
to shut down BAM for showing the right
pissed christ exhibit and actually was
the the Chrissa Philly the Virgin Mary
oh that's right I was the Virgin Mary
that's exactly right but uh you know to
me he stayed exactly who he was maybe
that was a problem for his presidential
ambitions but when he stood on a stage
of eleven candidates each vying to be
more right wing than the next during
these you know this endless series of
Republican debates when they did one of
these gotcha
you know raise your hands if you think
roe v-- wade should be overturned and he
you know declined to raise his hand I
thought that actually was a great he may
have been along with Gary Johnson the
only one who also said that they believe
in evolution yeah well but to go back to
the politics of New York I mean New York
is you know Bloomberg obviously is a
billionaire this guy knows how to make
money he knows how money works
he also was a nudge in a nanny Giuliani
had some of that he famously cleared out
Times Square went after the five or six
squeegee men that were terrifying people
coming out of the Lincoln Tunnel so what
is it what is the kind of broad politics
of New York I mean it's always a
Democratic City no matter who's the
mayor but you were saying that the New
York observers politics are kind of like
Bloomberg Ian or Giuliani asks we expect
you know you say clear down Times Square
as though that that's some sort of you
know fish stick thing and really used to
get call these crazy things but you know
we're sitting here is Italian yeah cruel
and vicious is that hotel on 46th rate
right so the people coming here and
spending their money here instead of
going to Disney World or Disneyland or
some horrible place like that are
employing all the all the people who
serve food here and who clean their
rooms and whoever it's to me it's you
know if you're going to buy into the
idea of of capitalism at all
then you have to you have to believe in
growth and and if you reject it and you
want to be an Occupy Wall Street that's
a legitimate choice but the my problem
with the people who objected to Rudy or
Bloomberg is they wanted all of the good
things but they didn't then they wanted
to wave flags when they didn't like this
or that individual decision and that's
that's the part I could never get it I
mean but does New York have to I mean
don't you find it odd and you're a
Chicago native writers your own items
right so I mean don't you find it odd
though that New York is like it's the
toughest city of the world it's out of
control and then you have mayor's who
are like no literally literally that
soda is too big you can't do that or you
can't have a strip club where do I want
to put a strip club I mean that but that
stuff gets checked that Mayor
Bloomberg's attempt to ban giant sodas
which I totally disagree with I not only
personally love giant sodas I you know
I'm here because I believe in freedom
and yeah it's tough you know there's a
New York for the big soda I did I know
these they're checks on that so he you
know he couldn't get that pass despite
all of his his power Rudy tried to do a
thing where you couldn't jaywalk right
he tried to put these these crossings of
like Aventine Americas in the middle of
the road and we call it works happening
yeah you know so is New York still the
capital city of America absolutely talk
about this it's not even worth arguing
there you know I was just in San
Francisco a couple weeks ago which is
the only other city in in the country
then I could see myself living it I
adore it
but even as it's on the on one of these
periodic rises that's a city that's
always in either total bloom or total
bust and it's in a total boom phase
right now it's just it's the scale is
necessary but you're saying that you
know say Chicago or LA that what makes
New York unique in the American
landscape the the the scale the there
there is every no matter how print weird
interesting your your particular thing
is there's there's a whole bunch of
people who share that and are right
there and have a group that'll meet
about it there there are these
New York has a unique ability for a
neighborhood to to spring up and be
great like overnight I was on Sunday I
went to some of the observer got engaged
I went to her party and got the address
and sent Fort Greene ten years ago you
you you almost couldn't have gone into
that neighborhood
yeah Fort Greene in Brooklyn and now
it's this beautiful neighborhood
beautiful people walking on the streets
every kind of race age income class you
can't have that where I'm in Chicago it
the neighborhoods that were horrible
forty years ago are horrible today and
and it feels like they always will be
with you know a couple exceptions around
those so I mean you see New York is kind
of the paradigm of creative destruction
these a the positivity of you know
capitalism and a mutation of creative
destruction that Joseph Schumpeter
talked about you know without getting
deep into the economic theory you know
just see it every day on the streets you
just see innovation partly because you
have to so what happens watch what
chokes that off though because you know
there was a time not so long ago
certainly in the 70s and a chunk of the
80s where New York was dead or everybody
just agreed up in New York was a dying
beast that would give off heat for a
couple more years but it was over what
are what are the necessary ingredients
and you know and this might be something
both as the editor of The Observer but
also somebody who worked with you know a
mayor I mean we could spend a lot of
time picking over Giuliana's record but
it's you know everybody says like okay
the city did great under yeah crime what
are the people crime is a big factor of
it and it's it's not for the reasons
people I was to suspect you know in in a
four years before Rudy became there
there was over two thousand murders a
year when when Rudy was done being there
was six hundred Mayor Bloomberg got that
down to about 450 and it looks like our
new mayor is doing a pretty good job
despite a lot of fears and hand wringing
over it that that's a huge factor and
it's not because those 15 hundred people
not murdered between you know yeah
there's two thousand versus five hundred
it's more that the the terror that
everyone else feels makes them disinvest
so you made an you disinvest not just
economically but kind of psychics in all
sorts of every you you might send your
kids here you're not willing to move
from your nice neighborhood Queens but
when your kid says should I stay here
and go down
whoo or should I go to Northwestern you
said Northwestern or you made a you know
made a remark when you're introducing me
as you know Rudy got those five squeegee
men off you're right it was a very small
number but they had a massive
psychological impact on the exact people
you want coming here and spending their
money it has you knows you talked and
it's interesting thing but that there
there are checks on the more autocratic
or kind of you know bizarre impulses of
leaders even when they're very popular
but you know how does when does that go
too far because you know you know our I
mean we're in the middle of an on you
know and it's every week just like
there's a new neighborhood coming up
there's it always seems to be a police
scandal and there's one now I mean the
police in New York are looking into
using excessive violence against you
know a purpose you know a person in
custody how you know how do you strike
that balance between creating a safe
place with conditions for economic
growth growth and tumult and then it's
just becoming too much like Singapore
that's a bigger question I'm prepared to
answer I mean I I see I'm my heart hurts
for this guy who was selling or
allegedly selling cigarettes you know
Lucy's for 50 cents and next thing you
know he's dead it seems like an
overreaction whatever the facts are and
I police have a very tough job and I'm
very reluctant to criticize him without
knowing the facts I think every one
police included would say that that that
was that was a horrible outcome
especially considering the alleged crime
it's too big of a question asked me how
do you how do you balance the needs of 8
million people vying for this very small
physical space with with limits on
government power but I will say I think
New York does a pretty good job and I
just rattled off a couple examples of
where executives push it too far
another one is Mayor Bloomberg you know
basically engineered the rewriting of
the constitution of the city charter for
a third term a lot of people are
outraged it was the key issue in the
Democratic primary this time but I think
there's a heck of a lot of people who
were pretty glad he did because when he
left office even with all this wave of
anti Bloomberg sentiment his popularity
rating was about 60% talk about DeBlasio
I mean because this is in a lot of ways
people are like okay we've seen this
movie before where you bring in a
Liberal Democrat
we're actually in the case of John
Lindsay in the late sixties a liberal
Republican
in the city goes to hell in a handbasket
or what are you worried about with a de
Blasio administration you know I'm
worried about some of the rhetoric Nick
I I'm not that worried about mayor de
Blasio as a guy I know him
you know I've interviewed him I
moderated a debate which he was like the
clear winner and and with very
thoughtful measured responses we
endorsed him so but I am worried about
the runner did you endorsed him in the
general election is that partly because
there's really there was nobody else
well is it his opponent happens to be a
close friend of mine um so I wouldn't
say there was nobody else but it wasn't
just cuz he was going to win it was cuz
of the masterful campaign he ran and and
I think that tells you something about
how someone's gonna going to run things
coming from the political world I you
know a lot of stock in how somebody runs
a campaign and I I feel like mayor de
Blasio is off to a very good start you
know with the normal amount of stutter
steps it's a hard job and complicated
job I am a little worried about the
rhetoric this this sort of tendency that
that he has to play to the to the
furthest most extreme elements of the
coalition that brought him to power
usually you see you see someone sort of
play to that to get their primary and
then you know sort of moved to the
middle to bring everyone in I think
that's a healthy part of of democracy
you can see that in this case because he
was winning 75 to 25 the day he won the
prize so you're saying he actually what
is creepy or potentially troubling is
that he in the in the general election
he or and he was rather he was more on
the way up he was more centrist and now
he's speaking to yeah a left yeah my
friend it makes me a little nervous so I
was some of the housing affordable
housing rhetoric around there is really
extreme and and I would you be able to
hidden Vince him you know that these
affordable housing scams are always
there always scams I mean you know like
is there any way to actually get a hard
left mayor to just pack it in on that
and say no you know the way that you
create affordable housing is actually by
taking limits off of the ability to
build more help you can never convince
people of that it once they it's it's
unbelievable Nick I agree with you a
hundred percent that the reason there's
no affordable housing is because there's
no affordable housing yeah it's it's not
because of this
exactly one artificially limit the
supply and you can naturally you create
these people who will never leave their
apartment if it's at all affordable and
and you have these artificial things
hampering it but once somebody buys into
the idea that the government can put its
thumb on the scale and fix it
you can never wind that back and that's
why it's so dangerous to start programs
they they just never go away let's talk
a little bit about your career before
you know before they observe her before
Giuliani and whatnot you were in a you
dropped out of college you were going to
a I guess it's a Community College
because it's named after a city right
University of Chicago yeah it's a Charm
School
yeah you dropped out of that you started
a band of some renown called green you
started a magazine also called green
tell us a little bit about the band okay
Mel you you were coming out of I got it
I got to correct your chronology a
little bit um which is that I joined
green the band which I did not start I
joined green which was already becoming
a sort of a local happening right out of
high school and I did that for four
years before starting college okay then
I did go to University of Chicago for a
couple years I think that's how I know
you you have wide varieties there why
did you drop out to find my fortune in
New York as a writer I moved to New York
City to to be with my then girlfriend
now wife and to take an internship at
Harper's Magazine and you know become a
media guy and then you and then you
started Green Magazine that's right I
start Green magazine while I was working
at a company called United feature
syndicate in fact the way I know Peter
Kaplan who was the longtime genius
behind the New York Observer is that
United feature syndicate used to
syndicate columns from the New York
Observer and I was the editor of those
columns so I would meet with Peter and
tell him how I was going to chop Hilton
Kramer down from 1500 words to a more
palatable Kansas City Star size 650
words rich is brutal because they were
worried that the Hilton wrote was
brilliant but things like that or joke
on ascend or whoever Norris indicating
so you you know but you have this kind
of DIY and
zatia element to your to your career so
you know you you you decide not to go to
college so you can play in a punk band
you leave the punk band you go to
University of Chicago drop out of that
you come here you know the next thing
you know you're advertising or you're
rather you're running the New York is
that sky why or a DD well yeah yeah baby
we'll call it a TD but is this the world
that we live in now and is it a better
world where you know I mean everybody is
finding their own path and you know what
is is there a through line to what you
were doing that makes sense and that
somehow reflects larger forces at work
in American culture I I think that this
this unbelievable emphasis on degrees
and credentials is it's absurd it's one
of the craziest things I actually think
it's a scam when you when you look at
what people do to their lives in terms
of debt its it limits their options
you're the whole reason you go to
college is to increase your options
right soso you don't that we're kind a
factor you can be an executive but when
you when you take on this staggering
amount of debt that limits your options
it's like you've defeated the purpose
plus we've gotten to a situation where
the only time how you performed in
college ever comes up if it does it all
it's like that first time you walk into
a job anyone who's had one job never
gets asked again how he did in college
so you know I I got a lot out of college
because I started when I was 23 years
old instead of 18 but had I go into
college like all of the kids from Clark
North who graduate with me in 1986 I
wouldn't have learned anything I was
just too immature and too too stupid
what do you look at when you're hiring
people at the observer you know how do
you how do you hire them as a base on a
resume or what do you know I hire people
who can write and who have passion you
know we have all kinds of people at the
observer who you know there's a long
tradition of people there who are
they're square pegs right they don't fit
into and they go on to great things this
is this city is an all-star team of
former observer people whether it's you
know Ben Smith who started our political
column and now is the inner in chief of
BuzzFeed or doesn't guy said well you
mentioned Joe Coniston Joe who had a
massive run in the 80s and 90s yeah
and Peter Kaplan himself who's you know
lot of people think was the best best
editor of the last 130 or so years in
the city and really was a huge
inspiration help to me
so do we live in a kind of punka fight
age and by that I don't mean you know
that people are wearing razor blades you
know through their cheeks or anything
but the idea of like yeah you know you
you just figure it out like if you know
you do you figure out what you want and
then you go do it and make it work I
think that's right nickel a lot of
people were wondering how I could have
taken off you know virtually 12 years
from being a daily paycheck earner in
the media and come back to be an
editor-in-chief of a respected newspaper
and I know the ones once respect once
was formerly a formulation yeah and I
told people you know give me a year and
tell me if the The Observer is doing it
so you look at my resume and it doesn't
look traditional that's it's a very
small minded way to evaluate this stuff
look at the look at the work I'm going
to do and then then make up your mind
some people some people love it I'm glad
saying so people probably don't but at
least hopefully they're evaluating
today's New York Observer based on you
know what's now a year and a half of
putting this thing out instead of well
he worked for this place instead of that
place all right well we will leave it
there and we can check you at every day
at the New York observers website and
every week with the New York Observer in
the print edition so that's right we've
been talking with Ken Carson he's the
editor in chief of the New York Observer
one of the great magazine or weekly
newspapers in the country thanks for
talking to Reason TV come thanks so much
for having me Nick
I'm Nicholas B for Reason TV